it is no secret the pandemic has
drastically impacted many families right
here in southern nevada
but for those who were already
struggling it made it even more
difficult to move forward
eight news now reporter kate houston
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
after speaking with a family that has
overcome many challenges
and the teacher who's now lending a
helping hand kate
yes that's right sasha normally teachers
are able to connect with their students
and pick up on signals that something
may be wrong
but due to distance learning that has
been a challenge
as a solution a local teacher assigned
an essay asking
students what they've experienced during
the pandemic she tells me one response
in particular
impacted her greatly i'm a huge believer
in
getting to know your students kristin
pohl has been teaching for nearly 15
years
although distance learning has created
some challenges kids aren't required to
turn their phones
out of their cameras on so i teach to
dots a lot
pole says some students have stepped up
and engaged in class
he was very open and to ideas and he was
one of the first ones to turn his camera
on
and he participated in class lots paul
is speaking about 11th grader j.j
rodriguez a bright student with a deep
interest in fashion
amidst the pandemic he planned a fashion
show the first one
ever done at his high school i noticed
him a lot but i was not at all prepared
for
the essay that he wrote i felt like i
was
i was asking i was screaming for help
and no one was listening
in his essay jj describes how over the
past year his family including his
mother and sister
were homeless and living in their car
but trying to stay positive
and push forward together we're in the
cold like
there was nights when we like you would
have to
open the car door and go to the bathroom
you know
i put on like a strong face at school
like trying to like
make it seem like nothing was happening
because i didn't want my friends to like
think bad about me
to avoid being separated jj and his
family temporarily moved in with a
friend
in october they received housing but it
was like another way of like
now we can finally breathe and like put
ourselves back
together despite this new stability the
family was still without mattresses warm
clothes and furniture
after a little convincing poll created a
gofundme account for the family and
within 24 hours i had over a thousand
dollars it was pretty amazing
now with help from the community the
family is focused on moving forward
together
i don't want my kids to give up ever
you know and if they're not going to
give up i'm not going to give up
paul is now trying to maximize these
donations so she can continue to help
families in our area the donations that
she's received so far are from fellow
teachers
as well as former students that she's
helped in the past who are now paying it
forward